hail Hydra everyone so you guys
requested an agents of shield video I'm
gonna explain what's going on it's a big
Marvel Civil War Captain America Civil
War Easter Egg that they're doing so
I'll explain all the comic book stuff if
you're new to the channel I do Marvel
and DC every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything
in careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet there are
really only a couple big arcs from the
comics and from the movies that you need
to follow in order to understand what
the TV show is doing it's doing a lot of
really cool Marvel Civil War stuff like
when they talk about the incident I'll
explain Easter eggs in a second but you
also need to understand Dark Reign where
Norman Osborn in the wake of Civil War
in the incident quote/unquote incident
that happens seizes power and takes over
from the normal Avengers Nick Fury has
to go on the DL forms the secret
warriors with Daisy Johnson and a bunch
of other Inhumans which is an arc that
they did on agents of shield season 3
last year then x-men vs. Avengers access
where all the heroes get their
alignments which so like all the good
guys like this Coulson technically loved
Hydra their alignment has been shifted
Ward who was Hydra in real life is still
a double agent but helping out the good
guys so everybody that was good is bad
and everybody that was bad is good and
then obviously Captain America Civil War
from the comics in the way they talk
about the sokovia incident there's
always an incident that people use to
seize power using fear and in this
simulation the Stanford incident from
the Marvel Civil War comics or the
sokovia incident from the movies is what
Hydra used to seize power and get rid of
shield then you had a weak state that
allowed a refugee from Bahrain a girl
sympathetic even though shield knew she
was inhuman they brought her back to the
States and put her into a classroom the
rest is history
but what inspires me is the way our
country reacted the way we came together
when no one would tell us the truth
Hydra step forward they brought us law
and order purpose they galvanized us for
the good of the state over individual
interests so in the comics what happened
is is in this town called Stanford a
group
The Runaways which is actually a TV show
that's coming to Hulu a young group of
heroes that's kind of in training goes
after a group of young villains
there's this big fight in one of the bad
ones that has explosive powers called
nitro goes nuclear killing a whole bunch
of people and it becomes this rallying
cry for the superhero Registration Act
they have these living weapons running
around we need to have them registered
so in the movies that was the sokovia
course and they call them enhanced
people in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you can't run around being this you
lateral force that doesn't answer to
anyone the past 40 years you've operated
with unlimited power and no supervision
that's an arrangement the governments of
the world can no longer tolerate but I
think we have a solution
sokovia accords approved by 117
countries it states that the Avengers
shall no longer be a private
organization instead you'll operate
under the supervision of a United
Nations panel only when and if that
panel deems it necessary
The Avengers reforms to make the world a
safer place actually we've done Tommy
captain do you know where a Thor and
Banner are right now if I misplaced a
couple of 30 Megaton nukes you can bear
the consequences so what the TV show is
saying in this fake reality remember
this is just a simulation so this didn't
happen in the real world of the TV show
so in this reality may did not kill an
inhuman girl and that girl went on to
create this big stamford level sokovia
incident Hydra use that to do a bunch of
fear-mongering and get people terrified
of Inhumans like look there might be
Inhumans that could blow up right next
to you are you worried about your family
we need to control them so they use that
to seize power Dark Reign Norman Osborn
style so if you don't know what Dark
Reign is that came after Secret Invasion
so the scrolls invaded the Marvel
Universe inserted masquerading as heroes
when they kicked them out Norman Osborn
took credit and use that to seize power
in the government so he
effectively took power over shield all
the big organizations and it he come
this dark twisted version of what you
saw before they called it hammer instead
of shield but that's where Nick Fury's
secret warriors a team led by Daisy
Johnson rises from in the comics so when
they did that on agents of shield that's
where that came from inside the world of
the matrix now the leader of Hydra is
Madame Hydra being played by ADA so it's
like the matrix only a couple people
know that it's actually a simulation
they're trying to wake other members of
the team up Coulson you have to remember
eliminated a loophole for their escape
next we tighten the noose Hey
who are you you with the other person
this is not okay I need you to remember
me I'm sorry we haven't met we have
please remember me
Kaycee so now you wonder what's happened
to all the MCU characters where's
Captain America if Hydra is supreme does
that mean he's an agent of Hydra now no
not technically
because they explained that everything
was fine till the Bahrain incident so
everything up to that point is totally
normal in the MCU all the Avengers or
the Iron Man Captain America all the
characters that you know or doing the
things that they normally would do so
what they're saying is this is happening
before Winter Soldier in the timeline so
Hydra use that as an opportunity to
seize power instead of the events of
Captain America Winter Soldier so just
like he did during Winter Soldier he
went to ground with all the other good
heroes so all the Avengers characters
the MCU characters they're still inside
this Hydra state because it's meant to
be this perfect version of reality and
just by the logic of Winter Soldier in
the way things played out with that
movie
they've doing similar things so they're
probably part of a resistance trying to
go dismantle Hydra one piece at a time
but it's much harder now because they're
very popular with the government
everybody trusts them because they're so
afraid of Inhumans so they are living in
a Hydra fear State with Madame Hydra
pulling the strings literally digitally
pulling the strings because she can
change the code of the matrix at will so
just remember this is all a simulation
but the idea what if is a big comic book
series it's just meant to show you hate
what would happen if Doctor Doom got the
Infinity Gauntlet so it just meant to be
like a worst-case scenario like what is
that big twist where the heroes one
didn't actually happen in the villains
one instead what would things look like
so just a whole bunch of comic book
stuff happening it's a lot of fun they
haven't said too much about what's going
on with next season yet but it sounds
pretty good like they'll at least get a
couple episodes even if they don't get a
full season order I don't think the show
is going to be canceled because Inhumans
is meant to be their real big new ABC
show that is going to premiere on ABC
even though the first couple of episodes
will prepare an IMAX but let me know
what you guys think about although what
if Hydra stuff they're doing on the show
it's a lot of fun there's a lot of
Easter eggs for the comics for the
movies even for the early seasons of the
show because they brought Ward back so
what's going to happen is is there some
cool daredevil season 3 stuff that we
learned I'll do a video for that there's
new Star Wars I want to
post-new Rick and Morty so I'll try to
get those videos out as fast as possible
while you wait for that you can click
here for that defenders teaser and you
can click here for a complete timeline
explainer for the reverse-flash on the
flash TV show and legends of tomorrow
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys in the next
video